[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MUSIC - "THE BALLAD OF JOHN
HENRY"]
John Henry when we was
a baby, sitting down
on his mami's knee, picked up a
hammer in his little right hand
and that little
piece of steel said,
the hammer will be
the death of me.
Dr. [? Wiesner ?]
received his doctorate
in electrical engineering from
the University of Michigan.
It was Archibald
Macleish, then head
of the Library of
Congress, who invited
him to establish and operate
a recording and acoustics
laboratory within the library.
And now, 30 years
later, what would
Archibald Macleish
say of Jerome Wiesner?
Ladies and gentlemen,
I asked Mr. Macleish
to step to the lectern.
I have called these lines
speech for an occasion,
the occasion
obviously is this one.
And I have dedicated them to the
occasion of the occasion, Jerry
[? Wiesner. ?]
Rinsing our mouths
with praise, tin cup
but a line of stones
spring in the cool
of a mint bed.
Earlier generations knew this
place, made their way here,
thronging.
And we have forgotten it.
We have kept to the
streets too long,
tongues stale, hearts thirsty.
Oh, to praise.
God's will in the world,
if we could learn it,
test it on our lips
with taste of praise.
Why else should the
world be beautiful?
Why should the leaves look as
they do, the light, the water?
Rinsing our mouths with
praise of a good man.
I say what I mean.
I do not say a good
man in a bad time.
All the times are bad
when the man fails them.
I say a good man at a
time when men are scarce,
when the intelligent foregather,
follow each other around
in a fog like sheep
bleat in the rain,
complain because
Godo never comes,
because all life is
a tragic absurdity,
Sisyphus sweating
away at his stone,
and this rock won't because
freedom and dignity.
Oh, weep, they say, for
You're not free.
It's your grandfather's
ich you're scratching.
You have no dignity.
You're not a man.
You're wrapped in a vat of
rewards and punishments.
You think you've
chosen the rewards.
You haven't.
The rewards have chosen you.
I weep.
Rinsing our mouths with
praise of a good man in a time
when men are scarce
when the word chirps
like a cricket on the cellar
floor, on the damp stone,
and the mind maunders.
A good man, look him
there in the fog.
Look, he saunters along to his
place in the world's weather,
lights his pipe,
hitches his pants,
talks back to accepted opinions.
Congressional
committees hear him say,
and not what you think,
what you haven't thought of.
He addresses presidents.
He says governments even
now still have to govern.
No one is going to invent
a self-governing Holocaust.
The Pentagon receives his views.
Science, he says, is no
substitute for thought.
Miracle drugs perhaps
not, miracle wars.
Adviser to presidents,
the papers call him.
Advisor, I say, to the young.
It's the young who
need competent friends,
bold companions, honest
men who want to run out,
won't write off mankind, sell up
the country, quick the venture,
jive the ship.
You'll see if NBC comes in
in Cambridge off that drive.
It fell under Cambridge police.
Let's just help each other.
Greetings.
Did professor from Berkeley
come to give us help?
Where' Ben?
Ben is up at the island.
Oh, up where the accident was.
One in a car.
Yeah.
And he will come and
say what the rights are
and tell them all of this--
one car, one cop.
And that will be sometime within
the next five to 10 minutes.
[INAUDIBLE] you'd better
stay the fuck out of the way
because people are going
to be coming out way, OK?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[CHANTING]
You don't have to
actually go out and ask
every student, what's your
opinion on this issue.
A lot of them
aren't going to have
opinions on any random
issue that you pick.
But you've got to
at least say, we
are about to make a decision
on this kind of thing.
Anybody who's interested,
please submit comments.
Now three years
ago, this institute
went through a big
decision of should
we have a medical school.
I didn't know about it.
I've been here five years, and
all the time I was here nobody
even suggested
that we were going
through that kind
of a discussion.
Why not?
Why won't student--
Why, oh, why not?
Yeah.
If we had to answer
for [? that, ?]
and because we had--
it was obvious that
we couldn't afford to.
I made a big hell
of a lot of sense
to have a big exercise
in frustration.
Should we or shouldn't
we have a medical school
that we didn't have
$100 million that we're
going to take the bill.
The only way we could
say yes is if we
could find somebody who
would match the government
money with the promise
of $50 million cash.
And Dr. Killian and I
just said, let's try.
And then we-- and we hit
five people that we knew,
or six people.
I don't know.
And then we finally
talked to [? people, ?]
some we couldn't
reach, who we thought
were interested enough
in medical schools, MIT,
and the whole thing
to see whether anyone
was willing to say, sure.
[LAUGHS] And nobody did it.
This was five days
after Howard became
president of this institution.
Six months before, we had
been totaling up the bill
on what we thought it was
going-- what we were going
to have to raise to do the
things we thought already had
to be done to keep
the promises that
had been made, like dormitories
and new buildings this time.
And that came to $200
million that we didn't have.
Know And I don't see why
that kind of a decision
has to be put to a
popular referendum.
I don't think it has to be
put to a popular referendum.
I think you just have to
say that you're making it--
[INAUDIBLE]
Who knows?
One of the students might have
known somebody with $50 million
in his back pocket.
I mean-- I mean, that's all.
We're faced with a question
of whether the decisions about
today make sense for
this kind of group.
I think it's fine to go
into the other things.
But I think we also want to
come to some understanding as to
whether or not we're
involved in a decision making
process that makes sense, or
is this another medical school
deal?
I love this man.
I rinse my mouth with his
praise in a frightened time.
The taste in the cup is
of mint, of spring water.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very
much, Mr. Macleish.
And now, as chairmen
of the corporation
of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology,
and on behalf of
that body, I shall
proceed to induct into
office our 13 presidents.
Will Dr. Killian and
Dr. [? Stretten ?]
please bring him forward.
By the authority
of the corporation
and with the enthusiastic
approval of the faculty,
the alumni, and
the student body,
and of this
distinguished assembly,
I present into your keeping this
charter of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
and invest you
with all of the
authority, privileges,
and responsibilities of
the office of President.
May you, Jerry,
serve the Institute
and dignify its
office of President
with all of the skill
and wisdom and dedication
which our confidence
accords to you.
And may your administration
be memorable.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, MIT's bright
presidents, an old friend,
[? Archibald ?] [? McKleish, ?]
for this honor and this
challenge.
And you, [? Paul ?] [? Gray, ?]
as you become a legal
chancellor, for being willing
to share the burden and joys
of leading this
great institution.
And a special thank to
Priscilla Gray and to my wife,
[? Leah, ?] for so willingly
taking the plunge with us
into the unknown and exciting
but obviously demanding future.
Dear friends, thank you
all for this occasion.
And I might just say
in passing, Dr. Killian
has made me realize that I
had something to look for to--
retirement.
[MUSIC PLAYING]